I have been saying for months now maybe
even more like a year and a half that
the 2018 elections the midterm elections
that are just five and a half months
away are going to be determining factors
in the future of the United States of
America right and that it's going to
depend specifically on voter turnout
there's this pathetically low turnout in
the United States in general and
especially in midterm elections the the
just pitiful voter turnout of
presidential elections is fifty to sixty
percent in the u.s. that is outdone by
the completely feeble fortyish percent
voter turnout in midterms and the upside
of that pathetic voter turnout in
midterms if there is any upside is that
every vote matters just a little bit
more right every person who chooses to
vote has sort of all else being equal
more power to decide the outcome of
those elections and increasingly it's
becoming clear that not only is the
election going to come down to turnout
but it's actually going to come down to
the turnout of the new activists of the
trump era will they go and vote and I've
talked about the explosion and political
activism that started when Donald Trump
was elected we had the women's March
with the protests will they vote though
that was always the question we've seen
after the Parkland shooting in Florida a
new wave of young activists many who
recently turned 18 driving very hard
around gun control will they now
register and vote and I don't mean just
the specifically the people from Florida
but everybody who's been moved to
activism by this unwillingness blatant
unwillingness of our elected officials
to deal with the gun violence problem
and what I'm realizing is that this is
going to be an election decided by young
progressives we can say Millennials
young voters in any case and there's a
very good article in New York magazine
by ed Kilgore which points out the same
thing and the reality is Republicans
aren't in total hugely motivated to vote
in the midterms right first of all
midterm voting is always down relative
to the national presidential elections
secondly there's lots of unhappy
Republicans with Trump so as much as you
some really motivated people who are
just so titillated and aroused by Donald
Trump's amazing leadership that they
perceive they are sort of counteracted
by the fact that there's lots of
Republicans that are really sick of
Trump and Trump ISM and many of them
might end up staying home altogether so
what the results will ultimately hinge
on and the so-called blue wave as well
that we hear about what that will hinge
on is the Millennial progressives will
Democrats take back the house will
Democrats take back the Senate will
there be a situation where we know that
whatever the results of the Trump Russia
investigation may be the consequences
will be what they should be without
obstructionism from Republicans in the
House and Senate and Ron Browns Ron
Brownstein pointed out that no more than
25% of eligible adults under age 30 have
voted in any of the past five midterm
elections in the 2010 midterms 12% of
eligible voters under 30 voted it's
pathetic right but it's a huge
opportunity because if normally 12 to 25
percent of those under age 30 vote in
midterms that means that if something
like 33 percent of those under 30 decide
to vote in November just 33% 2/3 of them
stay home 1/3 goes out and votes the
math is such that it guarantees that
blue wave considering remember that
younger voters tend to vote for the more
progressive candidates so if you're with
me the young progressives can make this
election one thing or a very different
thing then there are two major issues to
explore first of all there's the
micro-level what is it that young
progressives would be voting for in
November is it just against Trump I
don't think that that's good enough it
can't be the Russia investigation right
I've already said it the Russia
investigation I support it's legit it
must continue but it's not a platform
for the left so we've talked about our
guns a voting issue overall or not and I
think overall guns are probably not a
voting issue but gun safety has been a
big catalyst especially for young
progressive so I think that gun safety
should be a
part of particularly midterm elections
not identity politics but civil rights
when you pull Millennials and ask them
what's important to you civil rights is
very important it's something that they
care about so I'm not advocating the
sort of failed implementation of
identity politics that we've criticized
but I am saying that civil rights is
important employment has to be a part of
it another issue that is important to
young voters which really is part of a
broader economic message about an
economy that works better for everybody
that has to be a part of it and the
importance is that an economy that works
better for people will appeal to younger
voters in all parts of the country it's
not just young voters on the coasts that
care about employment and an economy
that works for them it's young voters
everywhere and interestingly climate
change climate change is a really big
deal to Millennials that's the micro of
the midterm the macro is we've got to
make it easier to vote and easier for
young people to vote why don't we have
automatic registration to vote when you
file your taxes or when you get a
driver's license or when you get a bank
account or when you go to college right
registration and every opportunity
because more young people voting moves
election results to the left and
historically it's been pretty
disappointing when we depend on young
voters to swing elections like if
historically you were saying we're gonna
get this one because we're counting on
those young voters
that's generally been a sort of losers
battle it's been pretty underwhelming
based on voter turnout numbers my hope
is that this upcoming election has the
possibility of changing that if young
voters actually get out and vote
I'm worried that the women's marchers
and the parkland activists etc are not
actually going to go vote yeah I wonder
why it is that young people don't turn
out to the polls I mean in 2008 they
turned out big for Barack Obama but ever
since that support is kind of dwindled
and maybe it's because you know young
people tend to be idle idealistic but
when it comes down to brass tacks you
have to remember to register a month
before you have to actually show up to
the voting booths and maybe they don't
think that their vote matters that much
I think number one it's scepticism that
their vote makes a difference and number
two it's that voting is a very habitual
behavior meaning
store this is why whether you voted
before is so important when you make a
likely voter model for polling if you
voted before you're very likely to just
go out and vote because it's what you do
when you're young and you haven't
necessarily you weren't old enough to
vote necessarily in the last election
statistically you're less likely to go
out and vote once you start voting
you're more likely to keep doing it so I
think it's a couple different things and
you know we know that lots of protesters
who got out on the streets after Trump
won didn't vote in the 2016 election in
part because many thought that their
vote didn't matter the Millennial
turnout in the recent Illinois
gubernatorial primary was three percent
three zero zero three just three I guess
is what I mean really really
embarrassing and I hope we don't end up
disappointed because the power that this
group of young voters holds right now is
just massive right older people are in
their routine they voted a higher rate
than young people they won't be as
affected by what's happening in terms of
whether they vote or not they just vote
if that's what they do the nimble and
dynamic nature of young people means
that there are a ton of people out there
who have never voted or were too young
to vote last time if they choose to vote
could make a huge difference and I hope
they will but I'm worried that they're
not going to the video you just finished
watching was made possible by you
through the membership program you can
sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership